[Música]
momento de hablar de ciencia y
tecnología en France 24 soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión vamos a
iniciar hablando de un experimento que
llevan a cabo científicos del
politécnico de lausana en Suiza crearon
un algoritmo con Inteligencia artificial
llamado cibra que permitió decodificar
las ondas cerebrales de un grupo de
ratones mientras veían un video y luego
replicar esas imágenes que veía el ratón
con alta precisión En otras palabras
mientras los ratones veían el video El
algoritmo iba decodificando sus señales
cerebrales en tiempo real y recreando lo
que el ratón estaba observando el
resultado es prácticamente Exacto
los responsables le mostraron a unos
ratones una película clásica en esta
película se puede ver a una persona
corriendo por un pasillo entrar a un
auto el ratón pasivamente lo ve algo así
como cuando tú o yo vamos a cine luego
lo que quisimos hacer fue reconstruir en
simultáneo lo que veía el ratón nos
preguntamos si podríamos lograrlo solo
con datos neutrales entonces usamos
nuestro nuevo algoritmo cifra para
construir esta representación latente
tomamos estos datos y los usamos como
base de un algoritmo de decodificación
neuronal y predijimos exactamente la
secuencia de imágenes que el robovió
cabe aclarar que la Inteligencia
artificial no sabía lo que estaba viendo
el ratón no tenía en su base de datos la
película las imágenes que ven en la
parte superior de la pantalla son la
parte inferior son el producto de lo que
logró hacer fibra al recrear solo
mediante datos cerebrales lo que el
ratón estaba viendo
esta es la primera vez hasta donde sé
que se logra con este nivel de precisión
ha habido intentos y muy buenos intentos
de lograr reconstruir lo que un humano o
animal han visto pero con este algoritmo
pudimos hacerlo con un 95% de precisión
en estas imágenes
creemos que es una primera demostración
de lo que es posible hacer con este
estilo de interfaz de decodificación
cerebral los expertos explican que no
consiste en poder leer la mente de las
personas o los animales pero sí que la
base de la Inteligencia artificial es
tan poderosa para entender con ese nivel
de resolución lo que el ratón estaba
viendo se trata de una herramienta que
según sus desarrolladores sería clave en
uso clínico por ejemplo con personas que
tengan algún tipo de discapacidad motora
si podemos usar estas poderosas
herramientas en entornos clínicos
podrían ser utilizadas en Campos como
neuroprótesis visuales que podrían
restaurar la visión o realizar
movimientos de extremidades Entonces los
pacientes que están paralizados y
quieren recuperarse podrían mejorar de
esta manera vamos a hablar ahora de un
par de robots de la empresa emergente
crover que exploran los granos
almacenados y según sus desarrolladores
podrían revolucionar el control de
granos tradicionalmente esos controles
de calidad se basan en un muestreo que
consume mucho tiempo contrario a lo que
ocurre con estos artefactos además los
datos recolectados por los crovers
podrían ayudar a los agricultores a
comprender mejor la condición de su
grano y tomar decisiones informadas como
aumentar la ventilación o tomar medidas
de control de plagas
lo que desarrollamos es efectivamente el
primer robot del mundo capaz de Navegar
a través de conjuntos de medios
granulares y entrar en la mayor parte de
grano para medir sus condiciones También
tenemos algunas herramientas dentro de
un tubo para recoger muestras y hacer
otras actividades que tendrían que hacer
los operadores de almacenamiento de
grano manualmente o que no podrían
hacerlo en absoluto el principal
objetivo del robot es comprobar que la
calidad del grano sea la misma cuando
entra el almacenamiento Y cuando sale de
allí así ayuda a los agricultores y
comerciantes a reducir pérdidas el robot
cuenta con dos partes la nave principal
que se encarga de Navegar en la
superficie pero también un dispositivo
en forma de T que es más pequeño y
cuando se despliega puede excavar entre
los bultos para identificar las
condiciones ambientales en las que se
almacena el grano en cobertizos o Silos
los dos factores principales son la
temperatura y la humedad para el
almacenamiento a largo plazo las
temperaturas suben los insectos
comienzan a desarrollarse a reproducirse
a generar calor el moho de las
micotoxinas Y luego el grano es
descartado y no puede entrar en la
cadena alimentaria humana es un enorme
impacto financiero para El agricultor
involucrado que está almacenando ese
grano
cerramos con la que ha sido calificada
como la imagen más nítida de una parte
de la tierra tomada desde el espacio
hasta ahora es el resultado del trabajo
de un satélite meteorológico de Última
Generación enviado por la agencia
espacial europea se trata del meted
generation y mayor One que muestra a
Europa África y el Océano Atlántico con
un nivel de detalle no visto hasta el
momento la promesa de la agencia es que
el satélite puede revolucionar el
pronóstico del tiempo el aparato fue
lanzado en diciembre de 2022 y es el
primero de una serie de seis que
buscarán proporcionar datos críticos
para la detección temprana de fenómenos
meteorológicos extremos al menos Durante
los próximos 20 años así concluimos este
espacio Les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros en
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]